heute gibt seine quickie schnelle
schnell runde hallo leute ich sie
darüber erfahren und willkommen zu einem
neuen update kalender test wie die heute
werden wir mal wieder naschen und zwar
mit dem vegetarischen adventskalender
von deiner mutter vom handelshaus huber
köln
ich glaube nicht dass es bei diesem
kalender wirklich erwähnen muss arbeit
dieser kalender ist nicht gesponsert und
jetzt alle dieser kinder gesprochen hat
oder wer weiß vielleicht hat hubert
könne mich dafür bezahlt man kennt sie
die influenza marke hubert keller
wandkalender kostet 24 euro 95 plus 94
versand und ich habe ihn auf amazon
gefunden er ist meine kleine abwechslung
zu diesen pompösen adventskalendern die
sonst so gibt das ist einfach schlicht
es hat die klassischen breche ich auf
tüchern und was ich persönlich sehr gut
finde ist dass er 100 prozent
vegetarisch isst ich vermute das
bedeutet keine gelatine kein bienenwachs
bienenwachs wäre vegan ihn war es wird
dabei seien aber keine garantie lasst
uns mal testen was da so drin ist ich
finde 24 95 ist ein stolzer preis stellt
euch nämlich vorher kauft für 25 euro
süßigkeiten im supermarkt das wäre schon
eine menge und das ist jetzt nicht so
schwer im gegensatz der superleicht das
finde ich ihn okay ist nicht viel aber
es ist jetzt auch nicht so ein hingucker
wenn ihr was ich meine
das ist natürlich nur meine persönliche
meinung ich mag es lieber wenn es ein
bisschen greulich ist es ein bisschen
dunkler die klassischen weihnachtsgaben
und halt nicht so fangen
natürlich ist das erste adventskalender
videos was er von mir sehen
ich habe schon einen sie sich keiner
länder zusammen mit meinem bruder
ausgepackt und wir haben uns beide
danach übergibt wir haben aber auch nur
zwölf und 24 tüchern wirklich probiert
deswegen bin ich gespannt wie viel ich
hier schaffen es geht los mit türchen
nummer
das hätte so cool aus gesehen saure
schlüssel
woran erinnern euch diese typen hier
steht nämlich noch so 13 gramm drauf und
ich darf mir so 13 gramm
ich persönlich bin ja eine riesen
naschkatze deswegen lecker und dass er
nur zwei schlüssel drin sind finde ich
auch ist eine gute portion wenn man
bedenkt dass man ja jeden tag ein
türchen aufgemacht und wahrscheinlich
nicht jeden tag so ein halbes kilo
süßigkeiten essen will nummer zwei und
schmetterlinge auch wieder zwei man sich
schon sagen es sind bessere naschereien
als in dem anderen für 40 euro weil das
aber auch so dieses gewohnte muss
natürlich in essen bevor ich mein erstes
urteil fällen kann nummer 38 pärchen
also das hat alles ein bisschen diese
konsistenz von schlümpfen dieses mal
gibt es sogar drei war okay aber das
konzept hat man jetzt glaube ich schon
verstanden
hier so mix also ich frage mich so mixt
ohne komik so mixt man hat nämlich so
eine liste mit den inhaltsstoffen
natürlich mitbekommen weil hier liest
man ja nie kann bekommt die nährwerte
aber natürlich interessieren würde es
von welcher mag das ist das sieht halt
irgendwie nah die katjes aus es hatten
nach geschmack wie ein aschenbecher
riecht ich gehe mal ganz kurz auf diese
seite hier www.dgap.de ein holländischer
shop mit holländischen süßigkeiten oh
mein gott
linz wilhelmina die hat meine lehrerin
früher in der schule immer für uns
mitgebracht aus voller diese tonis
schokolade oh mein gott das ist die
leckerste schokolade überhaupt wir sind
alben und nord hier seit einigen jahren
wohnt in hamburg blieben die schönste
stadt der welt aber müssen zugeben dass
wir ein bisschen heimweh nach unserer
kleinen heimat den niederlanden hatten
vor allem haben wir unsere leckeren
lakritze schrecklich vermisst also haben
wir die lakritz aus der heimat einfach
nach hamburg genommen hier haben wie zum
beispiel die frucht welchen die wir
gerade gegessen haben 150 gramm kriegt
man für zwei euro 70er super jetzt habe
ich ja zwei gesichter zu diesen
süßigkeiten jetzt kann ich ja auch nicht
schaden der dose ganzen investigativ
noch herausfinden wer über köln ist
herzlich willkommen beim handelshaus
huber kölner ihrem spezialisten für
individuelle und maßgeschneiderte
adventskalender
sind wir hier dem adventskalender macher
auf die spur gekommen ist so der hat
aber nichts mit köln zu tun da es in
viernheim in so interessant wenn man
einfach mal nach herstellern so umgehen
dass man da alles rauskriegt handelt
entdecken sie unsere angebot an vance
kalendern aus allen bereichen vom
bewährten klassik ein betrieb mit
schokolade uns sind und training
modernen kann denn dann ist alles dabei
die steht so entdecken sie unsere
adventskalender ja wo denn kuba kölle
kombi wir machen adventskalender
nächstes jahr wenn ihr das wollt dann
drückt auf den like button ich glaube
der bier adventskalender habe ich schon
getestet shopping queen adventskalender
habe ich schon getestet chupa chups
machen sie auch die sind richtig fett im
adventskalender brauchen adventskalender
bündnisses aufmachen
ich liebe ja auch ein bisschen
geschichte in den adventskalendern und
ich stelle mir das ungefähr so vor das
handelshaus ist zudem der krippe
angegangen hat gesagt hey habt ja so
lakritz aus holland und süßigkeiten weil
wir nicht nach bands kalender machen
wenn man sie so dass uns das mal machen
und dann haben die zusammen gearbeitet
und jetzt haben sie diese bands und weil
hier drop ihr gar nicht stehen nur auf
den verpackungen leicht hat das
handelshaus einfach auf der doppelseite
massig süßigkeiten gekauft und das jetzt
hier verpackt und schreibt halt die
seite drauf damit man weiß woher man die
süßigkeiten hat vielleicht habt ihr ja
sogar gesagt mach das mal das sehr gute
werbung für uns ja das ist meine
vermutung
[Musik]
aber ganz ehrlich wenn der sohn krasser
adventskalender produzent dahinter
steckt warum haben sie das design nicht
ein bisschen viel
ich meine mit vegetarisch wollen sie
doch auch junge leute ansprechen es gibt
ja auch ältere vegetarier aber es ist ja
schon so dass die jüngere generation das
macht dieses video kann auch als nicht
teste holländische süßigkeiten 1
millionen viertel also litschel ii ein
viertel mega lecker schmeckt so krass
nach melone und nikolaus nikolaus muss
jetzt geil sein
sauerkirschen
hat nichts mit weihnachten zu tun wir
müssen unbedingt die gramm zahl am ende
zusammen rechnen gucken wie viel gramm
süßigkeiten wie in echt davon haben so
sieht die kirche aus easycash
übertrieben lecker also wenn man auf
diese ziel konsistenz ohne gelatine
stehtisch möglich ist dieser kalender
auf jeden fall um welten besser als den
us labor adventskalender an günstiger
aber ich glaube auch weniger inhalt sie
cola flaschen ja das sind einfach hier
die klassiker colaflaschen ich hoffe ihr
wisst alle wie man colaflaschen essen
muss eine fantastische colaflasche genau
wie eine colaflasche schmecken muss um
ihr gott die liebe ist es gibt es auch
so im schwedischen süßigkeiten war
begann der die jetzt mal nicht probieren
ich weiß ganz genau wie die schmecken
die schmecken ganz fantastisch
wir sind beim lakritz angekommen ich
weiß es gibt sehr viele menschen da
draußen die kein lakritz mögen
ich mag lakritz dass hier noch nie
probiert das parlament lakritz karamell
lakritz karamell lakritz karamell
lakritz richtig lag nummer fehlt aber
ein paar tütchen überspringen
das kenne ich noch gar nicht saure cola
kirsche gebt euch das mal das sieht
lecker aus bogen die kennen wir doch
auch alle oder sieben gramm wir waren
bis zum ende wie rechnen die gramm zeit
zusammen dann gucken wir mal bietet es
ist insgesamt klassiker anders da kennt
man auch das liebig 14
[Applaus]
ich kenne diese schwedischen süßigkeiten
teilweise von ikea und teilweise von
sasse mehr videos weil die machen
richtig gutes anane karamell ich bin
jetzt ich der größte banane fällen aber
können die diese geschichte dass überall
wo banana roma zugefügt wurde dass eine
banane geschmack ist von einer alten
banane wies vor den fünfziger jahren gab
oder in den 50ern aber weil die sehr
anfällig auf pestizide war hat man eine
andere bananen sorte weiterhin benutzt
dieser geschmack ist der geschmack von
der alten banane ich weiß aber ungefähr
so wie auch so preiselbeere wieder die
gleiche form wie bei den bananen ding
aber mit preise wäre das muss probieren
hat habe ich noch nie probiert doch
konsistentes gut konsistenz ist sehr
wichtig weil sie den geschmack kennen
wir doch auch alle oder ihr habt doch
bestimmt jetzt alle gerade den geschmack
von diesen erdbeeren im mund
[Applaus]
hast du lust auf saure raubten
das sind zu hause trauten und vor in
hatten wir die tiere jetzt gibt es die
klassik schweine schmecken die es
eigentlich besser zu tiere weil die zeit
ihr amt recht komisch geschmeckt das
sind diese typischen katia schweine die
man kennt merck finck hat jetzt schwein
also diese katjes dinge sind echt besser
schon wieder diesen komischen
nachgeschmack findet ihn extrem
unangenehm möglich den 19
laura oktopus aus endlich ist mal was
gesundes drin ein obst mix mit wir auch
unsere vitamine bekommen einen 121 war
war das grundlegend sind sie hatten sie
schon sanierten süße kirschen ohne
zucker also ohne zucker aus warum zucker
haben sie ganz sicher 22 und rollos a
na klar hunte rondos man kämpfen wusstet
ihr dass das kondom 123 also manche
meiner reaktion sind ein bisschen zu
übertrieben das weiß ich selber da schon
wieder jetzt kommen wir jetzt ist
weihnachten willkommen weihnachten saure
erdbeeren
also hören will ich nicht gehabt wir
hatten schon mal süße erdbeeren
das sind sauer erdbeeren für mich sehr
interessieren milligramm sind skitouren
nettogewicht 3 144 gramm
manches ist der adventskalender oder
alles ich habe gelernt niemals jemanden
wirklich zu vertrauen deswegen
überprüfen wir das nettogewicht habe ich
den obst mix vergessen es kann sich
das waren knapp 334 3 144 gramm wir
nehmen das mal jetzt frage ich mich was
kostet denn sowas wenn es nur die frucht
bärchen werden werden wir ungefähr bei 6
eur 50 findet die gramm zahlt haben wir
dann aber noch bei 70 2 25 270 225 250
250 wir nehmen den durchschnittswert 2
euro 50 450 gramm zwei euro fünfzig
durch 150 schule in lippe die gerade in
diesen minen drin mit diesen zahlen also
zwei euro fünfzig durch 150 grad mal 3
144 gramm der warenwert wenn ich mich
nicht verrechnet habe ist fünf euro 70 5
euro 70 warenwert natürlich darf man
nicht vergessen dass es kein tv oder
douglas oder justice adventskalender ich
finde es mir gerade voll schade dass man
durch so ein adventskalender so viel
mehr für die produkte ausgeben soll
dieser adventskalender will timo einen
moment design wins kalender kostet 25
euro und hat einen wahren einkaufswert
von ungefähr 75
sie hatten noch so ein mengenrabatt und
sie haben fünf euro für die ware bezahlt
das heißt sie machen 20 euro und 20 euro
kommen natürlich noch lagerkosten
verpackungskosten jemanden bezahlen der
die sticker auf diese marihuana tüten
drauf klebt andererseits wenn man so
einen adventskalender selber machen
wollen würde könnte man theoretisch
zwölf verschiedene süßigkeiten kaufen
und sie auf 24 türchen verteilen mein
fazit bevor ihr diesen adventskalender
jemanden schenkt diese 25 euro plus 4 90
versand nehmen diese 30 euro ist zum
supermarkt und kauft für 30 euro
leckeren naschkram verpackt den
servierten papiertüten was ihr auch
findet weil also ganz ehrlich das ist
halt net ja aber stellt euch jetzt mal
vor so ein kinderschokolade
adventskalender oder so würde viel mehr
kosten als in halterin ist glaube die
können das halt nur machen weil zeit so
eine unbekannte marke ist und so aber
wenn er jetzt eine große firma hinter
stecken würde dann glaube ich würde den
fetten shitstorm bekommen habt ihr das
gefühl ich reagiere geradezu krass ich
finde nämlich fühlt sich echt ein
bisschen nach abzocke an nicht nur ein
bisschen also das ist ja die total süße
idee aber man bezahlt quasi 20 euro
damit man das machen können anstatt es
auf so einer tüte herauszuholen oder
keine ahnung
eventkalender ist komplett durchgefallen
im preis leistungsverhältnis im
geschmackstest lecker war daran ist
nicht das handelshaus kölle schuld für
den geschmack sind nämlich alwin und
nord hier verantwortlich dankeschön und
falls ihr hinter der geldmacherei
seitlich danke
und wenn man schon so kohle damit machen
will dann lass uns doch bitte wenigstens
in einer wilden
werkstatt oder so verpacken oder sorgt
für irgendein soziales engagement auf
dieser seite wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder biss dann eure meinung zu
diesen adventskalender gerne in die
kommentare und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten test wieder biss dann
[Musik]